18 t's the nation's fastest 3G networks
so you can download faster on your
smartphone than Verizon with 4G from
Sprint I can download files up to 10
times faster than 3G 10 photos in a
minute Verizon 4G LTE get ready for more
ads like those the wireless industry is
in a race to roll out 5g service now 5g
is supposed to be up to 100 times faster
than current data speeds could have used
it on Amtrak yesterday but it requires
cell phone tower equipment to be closer
to users than ever before and that is
causing outrage and alarm in some
neighborhood as antennas go up around
the homes Tony de copal is here with
both sides of the conversation
Tony lots of chatter about this good
morning yeah good morning there's
outrage which is also excitement I mean
a hundred times faster we get this
wireless companies in the u.s. say
they'll have to install about 300,000
new antennas for the rollout of 5g that
is roughly equal to the total number of
cell phone towers built over the past
three decades the faster network could
create new potential for work and play
but it's also leading to new concerns
and a lab in New York Verizon invited us
to meet some of the entrepreneurs
developing tools to run on the next
generation of wireless technology how
important is 5g to your mission a 5-trey
is extremely important Jonathan Reeves
demonstrated his product or vizio as you
move around the object stays fixed in
space look at that that's amazing
allowing users in different locations to
interact with 3d images projected
through a lens today we do we can do
this using Wi-Fi technology and we can
do it using landline technology but of
course you're then tied to particular
locations with 5g now we can begin to
extend this so we can actually speak
into to start doing this on building
sites we can start doing it on the
factory floor so it really opens up a
whole new world but before this world
can become reality
this one needs to change 5g requires the
installation of new equipment across the
u.s. so this pole here is 5g this is the
future right here you got it every
wireless company is working to build its
own 5g network Melissa are nolde leads
18 T's efforts if you don't already have
one of these in your neighborhood
they're coming
she says 5g uses high-frequency waves
that support faster speeds but don't
travel as far as current wireless
frequencies so instead of relying on
large cell phone towers spread far apart
they need small cell sites that are much
closer together we're gonna use our
existing infrastructure today whether
it's light poles whether it's street
lights we're going to make sure that we
don't make it obtrusive to our customers
and to the citizens yet some don't share
the enthusiasm the cell towers are
called small cell towers but they're not
so small when they're in your front yard
Donna Barron is protesting plans to
convert light poles in her Montgomery
County Maryland neighborhood in the
small cell sites this will cause cancer
she was one of several people who raised
health concerns at a government hearing
last month the stuff is untested on kids
their safety is not certain these
untested technologies are at this time
not ready to be unleashed into our lives
cell phone equipment emits radiation but
research on its health effects has been
inconsistent according to the National
Cancer Institute a limited number of
studies have shown some evidence of
statistical association of cell phone
use and brain tumor risks but most
studies have found no association if you
lose this fight and I'll pull those in
right here are you gonna move either way
Baron says she fears property values
could plummet when 5g equipment pops up
if a tower goes up right there what's
gonna happen to the value of that home
it could drop 20% and not only for this
house right for that house that house
that house and then pretty soon you go
around the curve and there's another
cell tower there all through this
neighborhood so it's gonna devastate the
neighborhood our nolde insist her
workers are focused on safety pointing
out VAE
live and work near this equipment - do
you have any 5g antenna in your
neighborhood yet no not yet I'm waiting
for it I'm waiting for it it's coming
soon though it's coming soon
so I'm guessing from that reaction then
you're you're very comfortable with it
rolling out in your neck of the woods
absolutely absolutely wireless carriers
have announced plans to roll out 5g
service to a handful of cities later
this year but don't get too excited to
really take advantage
you'll need a 5g enabled device which
probably won't be available until next
year so our current phones aren't 5g
ready they're not fighting ready the
pole outside your house might be 5g
ready but your phone is not yeah can I
have to upgrade you Tony Thanks